[Música]
salud en directo a América de Francia 24
me acompaña Marina sardinha en nuestro
estudio Marina bienvenida buena mañana
de viernes y hoy vamos a hablar de la
salud Marina en las comunidades
indígenas pero concretamente de algo muy
importante la salud mental usted junto
al camarógrafo estuvieron en una
comunidad indígena chanúa acompañado de
la organización médicos del mundo Marina
qué encontraron Buenos días Raúl Así es
hace un par de meses estuvimos en la
comunidad indígena en Vera dóbida en
chano en el Pacífico colombiano y allí
pues encontramos que tienen múltiples
carencias no solo físicas como la
desnutrición enfermedades como malaria
muchas de estas enfermedades víricas
también enfermedades infecciosas
respiratorias además también había unas
grandes carencias de atención a la Salud
Mental que precisamente médicos del
mundo Pues también está aportando a esta
atención psicológica que no llega debido
Pues a la insaciabilidad que a la
dificultad para llegar hasta allí fueron
siete horas en lancha a través de un río
también pues el estado no está presente
hay múltiples actores armados operando
en la zona y encontramos Pues que en esa
comunidad también conocimos el caso de
molanie bakiaza que es una joven
indígena de 12 años que el año pasado
intentó suicidarse Y es que también
debido a las dinámicas del conflicto a
la situación de confinamiento de
desplazamiento que viven hay muchos
casos de suicidios especialmente entre
la población más joven hablamos con los
doctores y esto es lo que nos dijo
Alejandro korak Que es médico de médicos
del mundo sobre esta situación y cómo
atienden ellos estos casos de
emergencias psicológicas
entonces la forma de intervenir la que
hemos tenido ha sido desde mi parte como
médico ha sido escucharlos Porque muchos
de estos testimonios nunca han sido
nunca han salido a la luz y he tenido
pacientes que se sienten enfermos de
algo que no tienen Y que cuando te
sueltan todo eso ese peso que tienen tú
los ves que cambian y es como Oye
necesitaba Necesitaba contárselo a
alguien que me que le interese lo que le
estoy diciendo porque aquí puede haber
venido mucha gente y no importarle y el
acompañamiento que hace psicología que
ha sido tan profundo desde la misma
cosmovisión del jaibanismo y todo esto
ayudado mucho para que ellos también se
acerquen a nosotros a contarnos y que
entre ellos también
se cuenten y se y se imponga Digamos
como una
una costumbre de que hay que cuidar
también la Salud Mental un reportaje que
también si usted quiere ampliarlo pues
lo puede encontrar en nuestra página web
de Francia 24.1 Marina el tema que pues
el que hablar y que vamos a ondar con
nuestra invitada Sí precisamente Raúl
tenemos con nosotros a Jacqueline
cerquera que ella es psicóloga que tiene
trabajando durante muchos años en
territorio con comunidades y Jacqueline
bueno Muchas gracias por estar aquí en
el plato de France 24 quería preguntarte
lo primero estamos hablando de esta
pandemia de
suicidios o una epidemia de suicidio
silenciosos dentro de las comunidades
especialmente la comunidad indígena en
Vera A qué se debe esto Cuáles son las
causas y ustedes como médicas o personal
sanitario Cuáles crees que son las
causas de esta epidemia Vale cuando
nosotros nos revintimos a hablar de la
comunidad embera pues tenemos que
entender que en veras pueblo entonces
hay muchos tipos de embera no Entonces
para hablar de El embera o en las
personas en Vera como tal primero hay
que remitirse a la ley de origen no
cuando se hace planificación en
territorio lo primero que se atiende es
que es la ley de origen que entienden
las comunidades indígenas por Salud
Mental porque pues el concepto de
suicidio es un es un concepto occidental
Entonces en ese orden de ideas hay
muchas causas por las que se han hecho
el suicidio y muchas comunidades puede
ser como un desequilibrio pero en otras
puede ser simplemente como un derecho a
la dignidad cuando se han vulnerado
todos mis derechos y no tengo
oportunidades si pensamos ya
occidentalmente Cómo se entiende el
suicidio nosotros hablamos de que viene
a través de la desesperanza aprendida
que es un concepto en psicología y la
desesperanza aprendida llega que las
personas tengan ideación planeación y
ejecución suicida en las comunidades no
tiene que ver muchas veces con el
arraigo del territorio tiene que ver con
las formas de participación que ellos
tienen con los frentes que ellos hagan
en la colonización por ejemplo fue
utilizado el suicidio como
una forma de resistencia habían
suicidios colectivos y ahorita están
bien Muchas veces es formas de
resistencia cuando se pierde la dignidad
cuando no hay formas de participación y
cuando hay desarraigo del territorio
porque para comunidades indígenas el
territorio es lo sagrados lo que los
conecta con el mundo y por ello tienen
toda la cosmovisión sobre el territorio
Jacqueline un gusto buena mañana Gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en directo
América el desde tu trabajo en el
terreno Cuáles serían estas dificultades
que ustedes presentan para poder atender
en la Salud Mental de estas comunidades
y además Qué tipo de enfermedades
mentales podrías destacar que está más
generalizadas dentro de esa población
vale
las dificultades de acceso a los
territorios son demasiado lejanos no
llegar a una comunidad muchas veces
implica llegar en chalupa en burro en lo
que sea que se tenga que llegar o muchas
veces es cuatro por cuatro caminando
distancias muy largas
Esa es la primera dificultad el acceso
la segunda es que cuando se piensa en
salud se empiezan en planes de
intervención colectiva el plan de
intervención colectiva va a dar paso a
entender los planes territoriales de
salud que ya nos van a decir cómo se va
a territorialmente esto también tiene
que ver con Los presupuestos los
municipios de apenda las categorías
tienen sus presupuestos y las
comunidades indígenas pues tienen una
jurisdicción diferente que también da a
entender que si no hay una articulación
de entender cómo funciona la ley de
origen de ellos va a ser más difícil
realizar estas atenciones frente a lo
que dices de las prevalencias de Yo creo
que es una crisis en el mundo la
depresión y la ansiedad pero siento que
acá como ha habido tanta influencia del
conflicto armado Pues todo lo del estrés
postraumático es demasiado
marcado en las comunidades claro
todo esto Se incrementa por la dinámica
del concepto y Jacqueline también crees
que desde las instituciones a la hora de
acercaros o acercarse a estas
comunidades se hace con un enfoque
étnico respetando pues la cosmovisión de
Cada pueblo indígena O cómo es la
aproximación
es compleja la pregunta que haces Porque
depende mucho del territorio y de las
apuestas institucionales que hayan pues
acerca de la salud de lo que les digo
que se plan territorial de salud Me
parece que hace mucha falta escucha para
entender cuál es la cosmovisión Cómo
estamos entendiendo la Salud Mental No
desde occidente como una ausencia de
enfermedad sino como la armonía que
entienden muchas comunidades indígenas
entonces siento que nos hace falta mucho
trabajo para entender y para reconocer
también Cada pueblo desde sus costumbres
tradiciones y arraigo al territorio
claro y también todo eso está
relacionado con el respeto no Jacqueline
pero hablamos en concreto del chocó que
fue donde también se realizó este
reportaje Pero qué ocurre en el resto
del país que otras problemáticas han
hallado en el en el trabajo de campo que
has hecho y también Qué grupo de
poblaciones son más vulnerables a
padecer las mujeres niños siempre
aparecen en este panorama sí mujeres y
niños comunidades étnicas comuni afros
raizales palenqueras negras tienen más
prevalencia todavía se ve que pues hay
un racismo estructural en la forma en la
que habitamos como esta necesidad de
subyugar a las comunidades no que han
pues generado ciertas cosas y la otra
cuestión es que nosotros entendemos la
planificación pues desde la escritura
informes y demás y hay muchas de estas
comunidades que los hacen a través de la
tradición oral entonces como que no hay
tampoco un respeto del todo de la
tradición oral de las comunidades para
entender bien Cómo es su funcionamiento
y poder dar atenciones realmente
adecuadas a lo que son entendiendo
también el ciclo vida porque por ejemplo
para unas comunidades indígenas no
existe el concepto de adolescencia claro
Entonces eso ya hace que cambie la
dinámica Jacqueline Lamentablemente se
nos acaba el tiempo para hablar de este
tema tan importante y tan invisibilizado
que aquí Tratamos de darle voz pero
igual gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros aquí en espacio de salud de
directo América de Francia y cuatro por
supuesto Marina Gracias por también
reportaje y como les recordamos al
principio lo puede ver en nuestra página
web nosotros pasamos a saludar a nuestro
segundo invitado el día